I don't think I would have been able to
do it without my friends and also
specifically my family
Lauren Bushnell opens up on camera for
the first time about life after
splitting from fiancee Ben Higgins the
blogger is back in Los Angeles working
on a new business venture and working on
herself there's also been nights where I
feel very alone so but I think that's
good I think it's good to feel things
and I think it's good to go through
things by yourself because I think
that's when I've learned the most about
myself so they've been very vital but I
also think it's been good to spend time
with just me and that reflecting when
you look back now do you think should
have done this differently we spent so
much time thinking about that because I
want to be able to be like okay maybe
this is what went wrong but in all of
the reflecting that I have done I can't
really pinpoint one thing I think it's
just a hard situation when you meet in
on TV and you meet and you get engaged
in such a short amount of time and then
you end up learning more about the other
person after the fact so you go back to
real life and that's really when you
learn about the other person I think it
just came to a point where obviously
you're engaged so the next step is
marriage and I think when it came to
talking about marriage
it didn't feel completely right look
he's such a good person he did nothing
wrong I did nothing wrong it's just more
like sometimes it doesn't work et spoke
to Bushnell at soul society's toast
friends and fall fashion event a ladies
lunch celebrating the brand's fall
collection with many of Bachelor
nation's most famous faces what is most
exciting for you and your career and
what's coming next
oh gosh I don't know you know it's
interesting I love fashion I'm obviously
like passionate about that but I also am
realizing that I miss kind of like a
certain level of privacy and obviously
when you're in the public eye and
vlogging or whatever it's a lot about
putting yourself out there and so I'm
trying to figure out how to balance that
and
so balance a level of privacy and just
like living my life so I'm trying to
find something to do I'm actually
working on like launching a Rosie I love
Rosie look for it not yet not yet we're
working on it right now but I think
that'll be fun
and I was a business major so it'll kind
of allow me to try to sort through the
knowledge that I learned however many
years they don't have a name called dear
Rosie like you're writing a letter
like I feel bachelor nation would
support a no other business I'm on
during Monday night it's a little bit
about the privacy I know you have a
maybe a new person in your life we've
seen him on snapchat or in your
Instagram stories a little bit how are
you navigating the waters with that I'm
very protective over it because it's
someone that I've known for a while and
we had a friendship established before I
even went on The Bachelor when you go
through a breakup for me at least that
was the last thing on my mind I wanted
to just take the time to like take a
deep breath so it wasn't necessarily
planned but I'm very happy and yeah
hopefully it all works out I don't know
we'll see he's part of the the dear Rose
a so we're working together which has
been really fun
[Music]
you